[Music]
jennifer lopez and ben affleck take
their love to the 2021 met gala the 52
year old triple threat and the 49 year
old oscar winner turned heads at
fashion's biggest night held at the
metropolitan museum of art on monday
first gen made a solo appearance on the
red carpet dressed in a gorgeous ralph
lauren number serving up a major leg
moment it just turned out to be
something really magical the hustler
star's western inspired look consisted
of a brown gown with faux fur sleeves
and a silver statement necklace which
she accessorized with a dark gray hat
and silver metallic platform pumps it's
about having fun
and while she didn't pose with ben on
the red carpet the two reunited inside
the event and even shared a sweet kiss
masks on and all
it's real it's a real thing the two also
posed together and for group shots with
the other attendees
benifer's big night out comes just days
after the two attended the venice film
festival together
it was the first time the two posed on a
red carpet together since they rekindled
their romance earlier this year
following jen's split from her former
fiance alex rodriguez
and while the lovebirds were in venice
italy the pda was strong they were
spotted kissing with their arms wrapped
around one another whispering in each
other's ears as they enjoyed a scenic
ride from a boat and if all that wasn't
cute enough just check out the happy
pair holding hands as they exited the
boat onto dry land we're having such a
good time a source recently told et that
things between jen and ben are quote
really working out on so many levels
quote jen is very in love with ben he is
such a good guy and he is extremely
grounded and selfless all qualities that
she admires and appreciates
ben is taken with jen and equally
smitten
that makes me so happy et source adds
that they're ready to take their
relationship to the next level and move
in together very soon
[Music]